make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right members of the Rob core uh we
officially have a discord yes we do we
have a discord server check the link
down in the description the link has no
expiration date and it's an unlimited
number of uses so you can use it as many
times as you want you can share it give
it to other people all that kind of
stuff
I do have a posted on Twitter I made a
post on my personal Instagram and I am
Rob Jefferson yeah so go check it out
there's all kinds of stuff there there's
basically a gaming section a
miscellaneous section which is like new
comic spoilers things like that that you
can self promote your own channel you
can promote your own artwork you can
discuss the verses videos that I do on
patreon uh for those guys who don't know
I do verses videos that I put on
exclusively on patreon for a patron only
content and then there's like an anime
and manga section there is an indie
comic section for those of you guys who
like indie comics there's a DC
discussion section a Marvel discussion
section film and TV video requests in
case you guys want like a character
explanation that's done or a story that
you want me to explain all kinds of cool
stuff right like there's all kinds of
cool things for the patreon patrons
there's a section there just for you
right so if you're on patreon head over
there and and basically sign up using
patreon and then you can essentially
connect your patreon to discord and see
that the patreon patreon only section
but yeah it's cool like I really dig
Brad I love talking to you guys all the
time right now where there's about a
thousand people that are part of the
discord already so it's pretty cool like
it's pretty awesome I guess it's really
been blowing up recently but yeah so we
are getting into x-men issue number
three by Jonathan Hickman now remember
when we first started house in powers of
X and I told you guys that occasionally
there would be stories or you would find
yourself asking the question but like
what's the point of this though this is
one of those but here's the thing to
understand is it's the same thing that I
told you guys everything that Jonathan
Hickman does serves a purpose he never
really writes anything in a story that
doesn't serve any useful purpose
whatsoever that character will become
important in some former fashion later
on down the line and that's exactly
what's going on here here's the funny
thing about this though is this story
initially picked up in the savage land
now I didn't even know the Savage Land
was being used anymore I thought Marvel
had discarded this essentially after
like Marvel now 2.0 or whatever it was
and they were just like who cares about
the Savage Land the Savage Land
is this landmass in Antarctica that
houses was basically like a lush jungle
Ryan you've got all kinds of like montt
like like normally monsters but you got
like dinosaurs things like that in their
species that were thought to have been
extinct on and it's been home to a lot
of different places - Kevin plunder also
known as kazar - many
one point he actually served I used it
as a base of operations but it's it's
it's kind of like this this place is
essentially hidden away from the world
and not a lot of people know about it
the general public doesn't really know
about it originally the Savage Land was
this old marvel mystery comics concept
from 1941 an x-men issue number 10 Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby basically updated it
when they brought in kazar and then it
became more of like an x-men concept and
then and Fantastic Four number 316 Steve
Englehart came along and basically said
that like the beyonders were the ones
who basically got ahold of some race
that existed in the in the main Marvel
Universe and had them create the Savage
Land right so there's a lot of history
there in terms of how it came into
existence and the purpose that it serves
but at the moment right now it's being
used by the x-men as a means to grow the
various flowers and so on that are being
used as part of their black market and
public trading company right the
Hellfire Club trading company and like
so many times that we've seen before
some group manages to break through one
of the one of the the gateways of krakoa
and then access the savage line here's
the thing the x-men's gateway system is
like the least secure thing ever with a
number of people who have managed to
gain access to the x-men's croco and
Gateway system it's like a person who's
got like a door that sits open with just
a sign just sitting on like a pole in
front of the door that says please do
not enter my home of course people are
gonna go in and T and see what you have
like if they're if they're interested in
stealing your stuff you've got no real
security measure and that's basically
what this is right so of course as soon
as I get in there they they immediately
spray down like pixie and a couple
others and and essentially you know it's
kinda like neutralized their powers and
that's basically it so what this does is
it immediately leads into gathering of
the quiet counsel and the reason for
that is because one the Gateway to the
Savage Land has basically been cut off
meaning nobody can get in or out of the
Gateway and two there's actually an
after effect as a result of this that my
whatever manner and whatever means this
group that's broke it in has managed to
find some way to basically influence
krakoa itself and so far that krikawa
has essentially shrunk down in size by
like 0.0001 percent like a hundred and
fifty eight square feet basically so
it's not like a huge decrease in size
but it is shrinking as well as having a
kind of psychic impact on the various
telepaths who were there in that area
and so as a result of that the question
is what do we do about this and so the
essential response is like we have to go
in and we have to basically figure out
what's going on now here's a cool thing
that that Jonathan Hickman throws in
here and this is
the things about Hickman writing but
like Hickman does not do like a lot of
writers do when he when he basically
creates a story and then like feeds us
everything in like six issues right
doesn't really work that way instead
it's usually always some kind of a slow
roll out because it's the slow burn
right it's one of the reasons why I
always love Hickman writing is because
he takes his time to craft an amazing
story instead of just rushing it all out
super fast and so as a result of that we
learned a couple things here about cacoa
the the island itself in so far that
Hickman really kind of ties into the
original giant-size x-men number one
story and saying that the crew Coen
Island basically feeds on the psychic
energy of mutants now in previous
stories that in in decades gone by the
island wasn't really in the Furious so
much as it had a disregard for mutant
life right basically it would just
consume the psychic energies of mutants
and then really care right that was just
kind of a thing that it did and it was a
role that it played as time has gone on
and especially with the x-men and the
various mutants using cacoa era as a
home it's kind of turned into somewhat
of a of a symbiotic relationship insofar
that Kirk howa if it really wanted to
could just consume like two mutants
every year in order to keep itself
sustained the one ends up happening is
that all the various means across kokoa
basically kind of provide it with with
some psychic energy that it needs and so
the result is that instead of taking out
two meetings every year basically a
ritual sacrifice is more or less what it
would be it just kind of feeds on the
psychic energy of everybody who's there
which is barely noticeable by anything
but here's the funny thing about this is
that Hickman actually brings back to
Selene and we've not seen her yet but
Selene is essentially the oldest beaten
in the world right she's ten thousand
years old she was born during the
Hyborian age and she literally feeds on
the life forces of various individuals
in order to keep herself sustained her
job here is to basically alongside mplet
is to basically monitor cacoa
and to ensure that kirko is feeding
process doesn't run arrive and then the
mutants themselves are sustaining krakoa
the way it needs to be sustained so it's
not a great big huge thing but it is
kind of a cool little thing to see that
like Selene is still here a character
who by all standards of measurement I
thought had just basically been killed
off and Momma was never gonna bring her
back but again like what you end up
finding out here is that these forces
that have broken into the Savage Land
are actually a bunch of old women thank
you for being the fridge so so these old
chicks here they're really just kind of
bickering with each other and carrying
on and and so on but they seem pretty
hardcore they seem pretty ruthless right
now we'll find out what the story is
about them here in a second but here's a
funny thing this is why I love what's
going on with with Dawn of X right we
talked about this during fallen angels
that like everything connects with
everything else and so there's kind of
this offhanded comment that's made by
him a frost like man I really wish we
had dud Ramsay that we had cypher here
in order to basically figure out what's
going on with with kokoa talked to it
directly but of course as we know cypher
is often spaced with the New Mutants I
think it is I Kevin what team he's on I
think it's a new meetings and so he's
not there and then of course Cyclops
makes responds by saying yeah that's my
fault because Cyclops is the one that
sent them out right he's one that that
helped them gain access to get to see
our space so it's cool to see these
little things kind of tying in to each
other but what they end up doing is
basically hitting up gateway and so of
course you basically teleports the x-men
or at least this this kind of strike
force team directly to kokoa and that's
when they start communicating with these
these old women or start talking to them
and like they immediately start talking
trash about Emma Frost they're like yeah
man we're a group called a horticultural
but one of them is just like speaking of
unsavory women like that one in the
white looks like a tart these old chicks
just like making fun of this young chick
is like hey look sweetheart you could
dress however you want you just know the
worlds are gonna kind of view you a
certain way right so if you're okay with
that do your thing but it's kind of a
funny little little scenario like old
chicks basically getting a hard time too
young chicks now here's the funny thing
about this is Emma Frost hits on that
right and basically says okay somehow
their minds are being shielded and
that's kind of a good thing right
because as we know Emma Frost is it a
mega level telepath right she's insanely
powerful so if she wanted to she could
just like shut down the mind of these
old chicks or or basically make them
dress like tarts according to their own
standards it's it's a funny little thing
like in terms of what she could really
do to screw up the minds of these women
but it's sort of a question there of how
is it that these women are able to
shield their minds from telepaths how is
it they were able to hack into the the
curcumin gateway Network in order to
access the Savage Land and how do they
even know about the Savage Land in the
first place right because it's kept very
hush-hush and so Sebastian Shaw really
begins to speak up here now here's the
thing about Sebastian Shaw
by historically speaking he's always
been a guy who over plays his hand every
single time without fail but a lot of
this because of the fact that one he's
exceedingly arrogant and full of hubris
and two because he's still kind of
riding off the heels of having once been
the black king of the Hellfire Club but
the idea here is that he's used to being
in charge and he's used to getting his
way and so where he usually is charming
and is able to kind of paddle way with
various men and women that are out there
by sort of using the silver tongue as
he's going through and talking to these
old
like you fair young beautiful women and
so on you know and and we can come to an
agreement right oh they work for people
I wouldn't come to an agreement they
immediately sprain in the face of gas
neutralizes powers and they're like nope
No Deal old man yes of course psychic
Uri don't responds in kind but here's
the funny thing is the x-men don't know
what's going on with this group and
that's one of the things to understand
the role of the x-men right now is
really more one of politics than
anything else and the reason why I say
that is because sure the x-men could
annihilate these old women hide their
bodies just be like Ricola take care of
these bodies are just like tumbling in
the ocean somewhere or whatever the case
says and and seemingly nobody would
believe that they were gone but they
don't know who sent them it could be
some foreign government and as soon as
the x-men make the first strike and they
kill these old women
well then suddenly comes out the x-men
are murderers right so not having all
the information not having all the facts
the only thing they can do is really one
keep these women alive and then to try
to figure out what's going on in terms
of how they access this area and what it
does is it puts all the playing cards in
the hands of these older women because
they control the game now this combined
with the fact that Cyclops is a sock
because like one of the chicks falls
down and she's like oh my god my hip you
know you broke my hip and he's like oh
my god I'm so sorry and she's like
sucker and it like sprays him in the
face I'm like Cyclops you suck grow some
balls dude that was my immediate
response I was like dude how do you fall
for that man like the chick breaks into
your home basically starts stealing your
stuff and then you're gonna help her out
where she breaks her hip yeah I want to
just kick her in the hip for good
measure and be like yeah man and let
that be a lesson to you don't break into
people's stuff next time I have kind of
cold blooded though of course Emma Frost
basically chimes in being well aware of
what's going on we get the story of
these various women here and what they
did is they basically served as this
kind of botanist science center more or
less you know that the group
horticultural itself focused on using
plant life as you know for various means
to improve the world or or whatever the
case happened to be but the issue is
that there were other scientists who are
using their research as a means to make
money and so because the overarching
idea of these three individual women was
to basically reduce the population of
Earth by basically initiating a kind of
extinction agenda and order to return
the Earth more to a pristine state right
so they're basically just a bunch of
tree huggers the result was that they
ended up killing off all these
scientists using their bodies as a means
to grow plants and then in turn continue
their conquest of returning the earth to
a more pristine state now the way this
would have worked is it would have been
fine but then suddenly the x-men pop up
from
basically saying we've got all these
medicines that can extend your lifespan
right and they can cure the various
things that would have otherwise killed
you and so it basically runs directly
counter to the plans of Horticulture
themselves so their idea was to one
analyze what it was that these plants
can do and of course they can't really
get their hands on them in a reasonable
way because of the fact that one they
don't really have the money to buy them
on the black market they're not part of
any real government figure or I guess
control center so you know they're not
part of any governing body so they can't
really buy things on the front face you
know in terms of like the the public eye
so they basically found a way to hack
the Gateway and then break it into the
savage land and then steal these various
flowers and so on so it's kind of funny
because you would expect it to basically
lead to them winning there's really
nothing in the frost can do here right
because one they're shielded from
telepathic without telepathic abilities
it's the only real ability she has she
could go running up on them in her
diamond form but all they have to do is
spray her with that weird gas stuff and
then her powers are essentially
neutralized there's really nothing she
can do to stop them and so ultimately
they just end up absconded with her
stuff right they just end up taking out
taking these flowers and basically
leaving and that's essentially it
because then she basically travels back
to the secret island or the secret
Council I'm sorry the quiet Council of
kokoa and says like we basically have a
problem here and this is something that
we're gonna have to attend to this is
cool
it doesn't seem super important but it
doesn't seem like exceedingly important
here but it will be right this will be a
major plot point going forward it may be
that it'll be like three issues before
it'll become important but it will be
important somewhere along the line well
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explain and make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]